>> Sean: TRACE, IT SEEMS TO
HAVE SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH
EPSTEIN.
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL TONIGHT,
SLEEPY CRAZY CRAZY UNCLE JOE, HE
HAS TO BE WELL-KNOWN FOR THE ALL
THE WRONG REASONS.
NOW HIS HEAD SCRATCHING GAFFES
ARE NOW A CONSTANT CONSISTENT
AND VERY SPENT DAY.
IT HE DIDN'T REMEMBER WHAT SADIE
WAS IN THIS PAST WEEKEND.
OF COURSE HIS AWKWARD AND
TOUCHING AND HUGGING IS BEYOND
COURAGE WHERE THEY.
PRETTY GROSS TO ME.
HIS SMALL CALLS IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
OR IOWA ARE NOW CAUSING MAJOR
CONCERN INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ESTABLISHMENT.
HIS DEBATE PERFORMANCES ARE
BEYOND LACKLUSTER AND TONIGHT,
WE ARE GOING TO EXPOSE SOMETHING
MUCH MORE TROUBLING FOR
JOE BIDEN AND HIS 2020
AMBITIONS.
NOW WHILE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
STRUGGLE TO MAKE ENDS MEET UNDER
THE ANEMIC BIDEN OBAMA ECONOMY,
REMEMBER, 13 MILLION AMERICANS,
FOOD STANDS, 8 MILLION MORE
POVERTY, LOWEST LABOR
PARTICIPATION RATE SINCE THE
70s, THAT WAS THEIR RECORD.
WHILE, HIS FAMILY MEMBERS WERE
ALLEGEDLY PROFITING OFF OF HIS
POWERFUL POSITION.
MANY OF THEM.
IN 2014, AT THE VERY SAME TIME,
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS LEADING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S
POLICY IN UKRAINE WHILE HIS SON
HUNTER TOOK A LUCRATIVE POSITION
ON THE BOARD OF A MAJOR
UKRAINIAN GAS COMPANY.
HE WAS REPORTEDLY MAKING $50,000
A MONTH EVEN THOUGH HE HAD ZERO
EXPERIENCE IN THE GAS INDUSTRY,
NO EXPERIENCE IN THE COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE.
NOW THE ARRANGEMENT WAS BEYOND
SKETCHY AND ACCORDING TO JOHN
SOLOMON, THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER," WELL,
JOHN KERRY'S STEPSON WORKED WITH
HUNTER BIDEN IN THE INVESTMENT
INDUSTRY AND CUT ALL BUSINESS
TIES WITH HIS FORMER PARTNER.
HE WANTED NO PART OF THIS.
AND THAT'S NOT ALL.
IN MAY OF 2016, THE UKRAINIAN
ENTRY OR ENERGY COMPANY THAT
SHELLED OUT A FORTUNE TO HUNTER
BIDEN WAS FACING A MAJOR CORRUPT
BIDEN WAS FACING A MAJOR CORRUPO
BIDEN WAS FACING A MAJOR CORRUPN
INVESTIGATION BY UKRAINE'S TOP
PROSECUTOR AND IN RESPONSE,
VICE PRESIDENT THEN
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN'S
THREATEN TO WITHHOLD OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS IN U.S. LOAN
GUARANTEES.
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE I
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE F
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE U
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE R
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE I
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE E
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE D
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE '
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE T
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE F
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE R
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE E
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE T
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE P
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE O
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE E
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE U
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE O
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE R
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE T
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE A
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE W
YOUR TAX MONEY, USING LEVERAGE S
LOOKING INTO THAT GAS COMPANY
THAT WAS PAYING HIS SON ALL THIS
MONEY.
ULTIMATELY, UKRAINE RELENTED TO
BIDEN'S DEMANDS AND SLEEPY
CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE BRAGGED
ABOUT THE WHOLE THING ON CAMERA.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE MILLION DOLLARS.
THEY SAID YOU'RE NOT THE
PRESIDENT, THE PRESIDENT SAID.
I SAID CALL HIM.
I SAID I'M TELLING YOU, YOU ARE
NOT GETTING A MILLION DOLLARS.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING A BILLION
AND I LEAVE IN SIX HOURS.
IF A PROSECUTOR'S NOT FIRED, YOU
ARE NOT GETTING THE MONEY.
WELL, HE GOT FIRED.
>> Sean: ALL, THE GUY THAT WAS
INVESTIGATING THE COMPANY THAT
WAS PAYING HIS SON A FORTUNE FOR
NO EXPERIENCE?
BY THE WAY, THAT'S NOT THE ONLY
THING THAT I TOLD YOU ABOUT THE
JOURNEY AND PUTS ANOTHER
CORRUPTION.
PETER SCHWEIZER'S BOOK OWENS TO
GREAT DEAL ABOUT THAT END
ACCORDING TO PORTICO, JOINING
BIDEN'S YOUNGER BROTHER JAMES
RECEIVED A GENEROUS HALF A
MILLION DOLLAR LOAN FROM A
WEALTHY DONOR ALSO WITH DEEP